Probablemente hayas escuchado que
el dióxido de carbono
está calentando la Tierra,
pero ¿cómo funciona?
¿Es como el cristal de un invernadero
o como una manta aislante?
Bueno, no del todo.
La respuesta tiene que ver un poco
con la mecánica cuántica,
pero no te preocupes.
Vamos a empezar
con un arco iris.
Si te fijas bien en
la luz solar separada
a través de un prisma,
verás huecos oscuros donde
han desaparecido bandas de colores.
¿A dónde fueron?
Antes de llegar a nuestros ojos,
diferentes gases absorbieron
esas específicas partes del espectro.
Por ejemplo,
el oxígeno gaseoso tomó
parte de la luz
de color rojo oscuro
y el sodio atrapó
dos bandas de amarillo.
¿Pero por qué esos gases
absorben colores específicos de luz?
Aquí es donde entramos
en el terreno cuántico.
Cada átomo y molécula
tiene un número determinado
de posibles niveles de energía
para sus electrones.
Para cambiar sus electrones
desde el estado fundamental
a un nivel superior,
la molécula necesita obtener
una cierta cantidad de energía.
Ni más, ni menos.
Consigue esta energía de la luz,
que viene en mayores niveles
de energía de los que puedes contar.
La luz consiste en unas pequeñas
partículas llamadas fotones
y la cantidad de
energía en cada fotón
corresponde a su color.
La luz roja tiene menos energía
y una longitud de onda más larga.
La luz púrpura tiene mayor energía
y una longitud de onda más corta.
La luz del sol ofrece todos
los fotones del arco iris,
por lo que una molécula
de gas puede elegir
los fotones que llevan
la cantidad exacta de energía
necesaria para desplazar la molécula
a su siguiente nivel de energía.
Cuando se hace
este emparejamiento,
el fotón desaparece
al ganar la molécula
su energía
y tenemos un pequeño hueco
en nuestro arco iris.
Si el fotón transporta
demasiada o muy poca energía,
la molécula no tiene otra elección
que dejarlo pasar.
Por esa razón
el vidrio es transparente.
Los átomos del vidrio
no se emparejan bien
con ninguno de los niveles
de energía en la luz visible,
por lo que los fotones lo atraviesan.
Entonces, ¿qué fotones
prefiere el dióxido de carbono?
¿Dónde está la línea negra
en nuestro arco iris
que explica el calentamiento global?
Bueno, no está allí.
El dióxido de carbono
no absorbe la luz
directamente del sol.
Absorbe la luz
de un cuerpo celeste
completamente diferente.
Uno que no parece estar
emitiendo luz en absoluto;
la Tierra,
Si te preguntas
por qué nuestro planeta
no parece estar brillante,
es porque la tierra
no emite luz visible.
Emite luz infrarroja.
La luz que
nuestros ojos pueden ver,
incluyendo todos
los colores del arco iris,
es solo una pequeña parte
del espectro más amplio
de la radiación electromagnética,
que incluye ondas
de radio, microondas,
infrarrojo, ultravioleta, rayos X
y rayos gamma.
Puede parecer extraño
pensar en estas cosas como luz,
pero no hay ninguna
diferencia fundamental
entre la luz visible y otra
radiación electromagnética.
Es la misma energía,
pero a un nivel superior o inferior.
De hecho, es un poco presuntuoso definir
el término luz visible
por nuestras propias limitaciones.
Después de todo, la luz infrarroja
es visible para las serpientes,
y la luz ultravioleta
es visible para los pájaros.
Si nuestros ojos estuvieran
adaptadas para ver luz
de 1900 megahercios,
entonces un teléfono móvil
sería una linterna
y una torre de telefonía celular
sería como una gran linterna.
La tierra emite
radiación infrarroja
porque cada objeto
con una temperatura
por encima del
cero absoluto emite luz.
Esto se conoce
como radiación térmica.
A mayor temperatura que
un objeto consiga,
mayor es la frecuencia
de luz que emite.
Cuando calientas
una pieza de hierro,
esta emitirá más y más
frecuencias de luz infrarroja
y después, a una temperatura
cercana a los 450ºC,
su luz alcanzará
el espectro de visibilidad.
En un primer momento,
se verá al rojo vivo.
Y con mucho más calor,
se volverá blanco.
con todas las frecuencias
de luz visibles.
Así es como
las bombillas tradicionales
fueron diseñadas para funcionar
y porqué son un derroche,
el 95% de la luz que emiten
es invisible a nuestros ojos.
Se pierde
en forma de calor.
La radiación infrarroja
de la tierra escaparía al espacio
si no hubiera moléculas
de gas de efecto invernadero
en nuestra atmósfera.
Así como el gas de oxígeno
prefiere los fotones de rojo oscuro,
el dióxido de carbono
y otros gases de efecto invernadero
se emparejan
con fotones infrarrojos.
Ellos suministran
la cantidad de energía necesaria
para desplazar las moléculas
de gas a un nivel energético superior.
Poco después de que una molécula
de dióxido de carbono
absorbe un fotón infrarrojo,
caerá de nuevo a su
nivel de energía anterior,
y soltará un fotón
a una dirección aleatoria.
Parte de esta energía
retorna entonces
a la superficie de la Tierra,
causando el calentamiento.
A mayor cantidad de
dióxido de carbono en la atmósfera,
es más probable
que los fotones infrarrojos
regresen a la Tierra
y cambien nuestro clima.